Since you brought it up,
let me mention that
these pans are not a traditional nonstick.
They are ceramic coated.
They have, like,
a special ceramic coating over the whole entire pan.
The metal underneath,
and then it's coated with ceramic,
so there's none of the lead,
cadmium, PFIs,
all those nasty things.
Another thing that I love,
since the way you put the handle on
is you put it on,
and then when you squeeze it,
and that's how it closes,
as you're taking it to the sink
to drain something or move it,
there's no way it's gonna fit.
You're only holding it tighter.
And then it's just super easy to let it go.
Since one of my kids is disabled,
this was amazing
because she likes to pretend plane.
If I have to go,
even just pee for three seconds
while I have something on the stove,
I don't want her grabbing the.
The handle so I can take it off,
make it completely safe,
but I can put it right back on to keep cooking,
and I guess it's there.
That's like some incredible nonstick.
You can see this pan,
I actually cooked in it,
but you just wipe it with.
I'm gonna wash it with soap and water, but
it wipes out like nothing.
So these pans are amazing.
They are non toxic nonstick
because it's a ceramic coating.
And handle coming off,
it's just amazing.
I love them.
The link is right here.
If You wanna buy some